here in new york city officials said
thank you to those who helped injured
and frightened passengers after a gunman
opened fire on a crowded subway train
this week mololenki reports on the
heroes of that terrifying ordeal
several city transit workers were
honored for their bravery in the attack
mayor eric adams the bullets were flying
33 be exact you stayed calm
stay focused
and you saved
lives i was shouting to the people
getting on the train among those being
hailed as heroes train operator david
ortiz who sprang into action as frantic
passengers spilled out of a smoke-filled
subway car in all 10 passengers had been
shot about 20 others injured i see the
whole car with blood so
of course there is fear
but then i had to
get the passenger to safety police
arrested 62-year-old frank james after
nearly 30 hours and a flood of phone
tips i almost couldn't believe it that
it was really him while on a class trip
jack griffin snapped these photos and
called police after spotting the alleged
gunman sitting on a bench hiding in
plain sight this is the leg i got shot
in hawari benkata now recovering at home
says he sat right next to the shooter as
bullets flew he tried to protect a
pregnant passenger and was shot in the
knee my hand was just soaking wet and
blood and i pulled my pants down and the
size was like the size of a quarter
and just blood constantly coming out
james is being held at this federal
detention center behind me on friday the
nypd announced that the 50 thousand
dollar reward that was offered to anyone
who provided information leading to
james's arrest would be shared among
five people whom they did not identify
for cbs saturday morning i'm mola leggy
brooklyn new york